welcome to this video when I'm playing
light like this Martin songs on the
right yep that's a German I am so we get
a wretched opening man maybe we
transpose to some kind of Catalan let's
see I can take on c4 now which would
make it all which would lead to
something more in ready style you Jack
you get the pawn back here and c5 yes
whom tend to forget the theory here it's
not something that I play that often
twin b37 and designed to try to make
sure he does not get in b5 want to be
right in time to prevent him from
gaining space with the beep on
not a six a four or something like that
so let's start with this no info i am
prevent be five mmm interesting do I go
to a 302 C 3 think a three-year not be
five is a threat now double attacking so
he has to go away six and now chan 94
bishop c 70 it's not so clear what I'm
doing there ultimately
yeah I wonder at the moment is not
threatening beehive but he might be due
to some pinning ideas okay
not so how would my plan is here this
position an interesting idea is to play
something like you for maybe do that you
know just take the high under control
and trying to play d 32 d for later I
think I'm I'm not threatening you five
but it's closed case just retreating
something like before would be nice to
get in maybe just put the bishop on c3 I
wonder if Bishop c6 as an idea for him
if I play Knight c4 I have night 85 in
case of beehive hmm not sure about this
okay let's play non-committal move first
if he goes Bishop see 694 beehive takes
takes Knight a5 is gaining a bit in
strength as the bishop is a texture ok
just there
yeah let's put it in to jump to a five
in case of b5 if I can look the Queen
and get in before it would be quite nice
I wonder can I manage that seagoing
night f8 or something
let's go back he can kill you can play a
b5 anyway so just going back try for
before possible okay I'm trying to play
before him Rukia one probably wasn't the
most successful idea yeah difficult
strategic position I came let's take and
go here now before yeah before it's got
c4 though hmm that's true
I need to prepare that so okay let's
just make sure he does not go see for
and play like Bishop see 39 ft 2 and
then before oh ok just going in for that
trade good idea probably ok let's take
looks a bit strange to trade this from a
dark squares a week but his c5 pawn is
also a bit under pressure I'm actually
down on time really I mean I heard like
he's playing very slowly but slowly I
was playing like super slowly so let's
go here indirectly looking at that c5
porn
should be five Bishop one it's a very
strange position don't think it that bad
for me this deep one looks honey but his
bishop owner aid is also quite a strange
piece and c5 is something that I can
attack it's just not clear if I can ever
strengthen the whole thing Kim that's a
problem
that's not ideal time morning it's not
ideal at all he might have c4 now if
500k the long diagonal is an issue I
don't have to play quit now quickly
hmm Jim it was difficult difficult
difficult position take them can maybe
take your form yeah the Queen comin on
the long diagonal is a big issue here
rook c8 is probably winning no I've got
rooked III that's the only the little
tricky at least
it doesn't have a great Queen Queen
Square still very problematic oops how
could she too okay Campbell and to take
that and now I've got a winning position
probably but ok I'm actually had on time
so okies going to g5 okay so let's take
that it's just just uncheck you might
draw here but check I couldn't check can
write something better let's be five
check my t7 was a big Fork but he
prevented to check six oops his pawn his
point is very quick no no check check I
don't know I always feel bad tried to
win those kind of nonsensical games on
time when I'm well he I'm completely
winning of course and instead I screw it
up and he screws it up and said I don't
know ok now when I was in a very
probably in a very bad state around here
but I wasn't so sure it looks a bit
strange to hold the whole situation here
because well it feels like this is a bad
setup but the bishop 18 is also not
great maybe I'm I'm ok the engine gets
black a slight advantage I know he's
that's a big advantage because of this
move which is very strong ok
yeah I obviously cannot take that's
going to get checkmated so he manages
that then I'm falling apart yeah after
that I'm actually okay before was even
good for what I didn't see this point
while that's strong that's really strong
white is much better him Wow ok amazing
yeah and here I'm in trouble Jim he five
was good Jim Jim here well he blundered
into that but he can probably win
somehow with e five year this introduces
oops not that one hair Queen Queen to h3
and oops here like Windsor there was a
very up and down game she either said
it's a it's a total win night be 7s even
even stronger 6v6 okay that sets a very
easy one actually just winning the half
with the exchange up yeah can then also
wins of course but I screwed it up
afterwards okay well thanks for watching